and so I said it's actually people like
this that need to be shamed out of
marriage they ruined it for the people
that actually believe in marriage and
that's what you got a lot of fake wives
a lot of fake wives that don't believe
in submission a lot of fake wives that
Nag on their husbands constantly a lot
of fake wives that give their kids to
daycare instead of raising them a lot of
fake wives that don't cook for their
family a lot of fake wives that really
Bamboozled their husband that have these
crazy paths that they didn't tell their
husbands about and you know it's one
thing to come in with like humility
right and I you know I think the most
women I wouldn't advise men to go for
women with a past pretty much ever
because we just yeah but you know the
women that do make changes and men too
right they come in with some humility
but it's like this arrogance and this
this deserving that I can't stand I
really think very few people deserve
marriage